two key members of the House
Intelligence Committee are at odds
committee chairman Devon Nunez is
accused by the ranking Democrat Adam
Schiff of trying to divert attention
from president Trump's unproven claimed
that he was wiretapped by President
Obama Jeff the gaze has more the
president made a slanderous accusation
against his predecessor one with
absolutely no basis the Intelligence
Committee ranking Democrat Adam Schiff
accused Republican chairman Devin Nunez
of trying to muddy the waters that
effort to defend the indefensible has
led us down this terrible rabbit hole
and threatens the integrity of the only
investigation that's authorized in the
house Nunez announced two developments
in that investigation into Russian
meddling and allegations of Trump
campaign collusion in the 2016 election
that former Trump campaign chairman Paul
Manafort whose relationship to Russian
oligarch Oleg Deripaska has come under
scrutiny has volunteered to testify and
the committee will hear from FBI
director James Comey and NSA director
michael rogers in a closed session next
week instead of public testimony from
former obama administration officials in
a tweet Schiff accused Nunez of wanting
to choke off information from the public
on Wednesday Nunez rushed to the White
House to tell the president about what
he said was legal foreign surveillance
that involved members of the Trump
transition team I have seen intelligence
reports that clearly show that the
president-elect and his team were I
guess it at least monitored and
disseminated out in intelligence but
when asked about the surveillance
morning was less certain about what he
had seen on a short notice we won't know
that until we actually receive all of
the documentation it's hard to know
where the information came from until
you get the reports and have time to go
through them and see all the sourcing of
the documents meanwhile newness also
repeated something that he said last
week that there is no evidence President
Obama wiretapped Trump Tower for CBS
this morning saturday I'm Jeff 'begaze
Washington